something's not right
follow me bastard
if there anyone in there or are you just
an animal
Superman ins fighting amongst the people
that love and adore him this is Superman
and the fight for his life that we've
never seen him before it's a lot more
emotionally shattering when the end
finally comes for him in this movie
we've got 30 seconds you need two fire
engines now in this movie doomsday is a
bit of a mystery you take all of the
dangerous elements of Superman remove
the conscience put it in this vessel
that can channel all that anger rage and
power you have doomsday doomsday is a
threat that they've never seen before
they've never faced before even more so
than Darkseid we've really got a bigger
group than they've had for any of these
movies before fighting just one entity
so the more they battle it the stronger
it gets we raised you so that you could
be yourself we didn't raise you to be
alone honey
this movie is a lot about relationships
and the different kinds of ways
relationships present themselves to one
person we see more of Superman's world
doomsday Superman is something that the
DC fans are very familiar with we really
wanted to warrant retelling this story
and putting it in this continuity and in
this universe this movie is actually the
first act of what the first original
movie was his plight at the start of the
movie is whether or not to share his
life further with Lois I feel like it
scares you that I might get to the truth
Clark
kal-el Superman taxi he's got this
identity crisis kind of going on do I
stay human do I do I be the hero
do I let Lois in there's a reason why
I'm so secretive and he's willing to not
only admit finally that he's in love
with this person and make this
connection by revealing who he really is
but then on another level he's willing
to sacrifice all that we have other
characters that weren't in the first
movie we incorporate the Justice League
in this movie as well okay next up a lot
of their scenes in this movie are
basically scenes where he's asking their
advice aren't you worried about what
about bringing her into your world the
dangers the sacrifice Lois is us in this
movie
there's something very vulnerable about
that hopefully that's an element that
the audience can relate to I feel like I
say there's a couple of times a week but
thanks Superman
I don't know what we'd do without you we
definitely wanted to touch on the idea
that Superman's existence who he is as a
person
affects everyone in this movie we
introduced bibo who's has no real
connection to Superman other than he's a
huge fan how about a picture for the
joint I really filled in the producers
do a great job with setting up that
likability from bibo that relatability
is a stupid thing story of him being
saved in connection to and all the other
characters say Superman Superman and so
he's our touchstone in the story that
connects this story to what fans feel
about Superman hey if you ain't got a
place to go you can stay with me while
Superman cleans this clown's clock real
justice isn't reserved for some it's
everyone's right Jerry O'Connell who
voices our Superman has done a fantastic
job and Lois and this movie really had a
very pivotal role and so for us it
popped into our heads that Rebecca
Romain would be a great choice thanks
for the ride as far as their connection
as being husband and wife I think
there's a familiarity there are you sure
you're not just getting old you'll have
to tell me what that's like ah super
Touche it was just so much fun to see
them bring that to life we need you
Clark
Jason tomorrow's our Batman again
returned in this continuity of films
they're really comfortable in the role
Batman zipline shemar Moore has been
cyborg since Justice League war and he
comes in with such enthusiasm where is
that monstrosity rosario dawson is so
much fun as our Wonder Woman she just
really brings down away the toughness
but the humor where it's needed towel I
don't sweat maybe not on the outside no
real thoughts it's all aggression all
about the fight a killing machine can
the comic the fight was staged very it
starts very wide and we progressively
get tighter and tighter and tighter in
the panel's get bigger and bigger and
bigger and so we wanted to kind of
replicate that feeling in the movie
Superman is an emotional investment and
stopping doomsday the idea that he may
not survive is the first time he's ever
had to deal with that kind of emotion
there's a point where we see the
realization in his eyes this is a thing
that he may not be able to be
as a fan but I want to see that depth
and and the idea that this sacrifice
feels like it was given the weight to
mean something to try to push for
something different was was a really
really fun opportunity to do on this
movie it fired off on all cylinders like
yeah let's really bring something unique
to this but also have it still feel very
reminiscent of the comic book The Death
of Superman was something that I think
convict fans thought was unthinkable
I gave fans a chance to realize how much
the character means to them I'm blown
away by seeing Superman that vulnerable
he's willing to sacrifice to save not
only Lois Lane but everyone the biggest
hero in the world can be killed and
anything as can happen in this universe
if anyone's watching help
hey everybody its Charlie so they
released an extended preview for the
death of Superman movie that's coming up
they're doing the death of Superman and
the return of Superman obviously the
return of Superman won't be released
till next year but they haven't actually
said when this movie is coming out they
just say spring 2018 I'm assuming it'll
be in the next month or two for the most
part as you can see this is set in the
Justice League war continuity so like
Justice League vs Teen Titans the judice
contract everything set within what you
would think of is the main DC Universe
films they did a recent Batman Harley
Quinn film with Kevin Conroy and the
rest of the cast from Batman the
Animated Series
that's not canon with what's going on
here so like the Suicide Squad held to
pay movie that just dropped today that's
canon to this Death of Superman movie so
we think most of you have a pretty good
idea of where these animated movies fall
I haven't been a huge fan of Jerry
O'Connell Superman but for the most part
they have a pretty solid cast in terms
of DC animation I'm Way more excited
about Young Justice season 3 but they
still have a long ways to go on
animating those episodes there's gonna
be 26 episodes it's not gonna drop to
like November or December we don't have
an actual release day we just know
fourth-quarter as of right now they have
partial animation on most of the
episodes they've recorded most of the
voice dialogue obviously they'll
probably do pickups later this year as
they finish more animation and they
change things down the line or do they
decide they want to make some different
choices with some of the dialogue but as
of the last big update none of the
episodes are like 100% done picture lock
so I just expect to get more updates
especially at Comic Con this summer
probably the first trailer for that at
whatever Comic Con panel they do this
summer and also updates about that DC
streaming service that we don't know
anything about yet if you are brand new
to the channel be sure to subscribe to
get all those videos I know a lot of
people are wondering if it's gonna be
dropping binge style like Netflix or if
it'll be week to week I know a little
bit more about what's going on with
Titan season one than I do with Young
Justice season 3 just because
live-action is a little more predictable
but everybody just let me know what you
think of the animated movies so far and
I'm still working on new flash new
legends of tomorrow and there's some new
Titans Batman stuff later today so a
whole bunch of DC stuff posting today
while you wait for everything click here
for my Krypton
episode 1 video if you haven't seen it
yet and click here for brand new flash
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight